فقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسي انها اجرت
امس الثلاثاء اختبارا ناجحا لاطلاق صاروخ
باليستي عابر للقارات من حقل كابوسين يار
بمقاطعه
استرخان جنوب غربي البلاد اصابه هدفه
الوهمي بدقه في حقل ساري في كازاخستان
يشير بيان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الى ان
الغرض من عمليه الاطلاق كان اختبار
المعدات القتاليه المتقدمه للصواريخ
الباليستيه العابره للقارات هذا وقد اشارت
الخارجيه الروسيه الى ان موسكو اخطرت
واشنطن بعمليه اطلاق الصاروخ البالستيف
العابر للقارات انا من موسكو مدير مكتب
الجزيره زاور شاوج ادنزاور ماذا بخصوص هذه
التجربه لهذا الصاروخ البالستي العابر
للقارات
نعم عبد القادر الحقيقه استوقفنا انه لاول
مره في بيانات وزاره الدفاع على الاقل في
المرحله الاخيره لم تذكر ما هو طراز هذا
الصاروخ سواء انها قالت ان انها انها
تجربه هي على راس حربي
تتعامل به روسيا على انه من الاسلحه
المستقبليه وكيفيه ملائمته لتصميم هذا
الصاروخ اذا تحدثنا عن جغرافيه المكان
الذي تمت به هذه التجربه فهو في جنوب غرب
روسيا تحديدا في منطقه او مقاطعه اسرخن
المطله على بحر قزوين نتحدث عن القسم
الجنوبي من الاراضي الروسيه وصاروخ سقط في
حقل تجارب سوفيتي سابق في كازاخستان يعرف
باسم سرير شقان وتستخدمه عاده روسيا
لاطلاق هذا النوع من الصواريخ المعروف فقط
هو انه لم يطلق من منجم وانما اطلق من على
عربه النقل وبالتالي هناك تساؤلات كبيره
حول طراز هذا الصاروخ واقتصدت ربما وزاره
الدفاع ان تلتقط صور ليليه لعدم معرفه هذا
الصاروخ ولكن ايضا من الملفت ما ذكره نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي عبد القادر
اليوم فيما يتعلق بهذه التجربه ان موسكو
اخطرت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بهذه
التجربه رغم ان روسيا علقت مشاركه
مشاركتها كما نعلم باتفاقيه ستارت ثلاثه
قبل اسابيع
ولكنها ما تزال ملتزمه باخطار الجانب
الامريكي عن اولا التجارب الصاروخيه
وثانيا عن التحركات للاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
كما نعلم قبل نحو اسبوع كانت هناك
تدريبات ميدانيه في وسط روسيا في المنطقه
العسكريه الوسطى لسلاحه صواريخ
الاستراتيجيه على مساحات واسعه يبقى في
البعد السياسي بدون شك هذه التجارب وهذه
التحركات الاستراتيجيه ليست مرتبطه فقط
بما يج اوكرانيا ولكن ايضا في منطقه جنوب
شرق اسيا وتوتر حول تايوان واتواجد
العسكري الامريكي براي روسيا المهدده
لاستقرارها في منطقه المحيط الهادي
والمنطقه الشرقيه في اقصى الشرق الروسي
وهناك ايضا بين الحين والاخر تجري السفن
الحربيه الروسيه
تجارب وتدريبات باستخدام صواريخ ايضا فرط
صوتيه حديثه نشرتها مؤخرا على السفن
والغواصات الروسيه عبد القادر مدير مكتب
الجزيره شكرا جزيلا لك